hey guys this is vadim with maxtec and
in this
oh sorry guys our new premium apple
product mask is so comfy i almost forgot
i still had it on
you should definitely go check it out in
our merch shelf right below this video
because if we're in this thing for the
long haul then we may as well do it in
style
thanks to recent rumors and leaks it's
becoming more and more likely that the
very first apple silicon mac
is gonna be a 13-inch macbook pro now
you probably have a ton of questions
like what about the 14 inch display size
or what about the macbook air or the
imac
or maybe there will be a revival of the
12-inch macbook
is the apple silicon 16-inch macbook pro
coming this year
should i wait for the new rmax or just
buy an
intel mac right now is apple silicon
actually going to be as fast as current
intel max
what about that intel imac that i
mentioned was going to be released
very soon should we expect touchscreen
displays
to finally come to the mac the answer to
that last question
is actually no and i'll explain why in
just a minute
but first i want to go through those
other questions let's start with the
reason why i think the 13 inch macbook
pro is gonna be the first
apple silicon mac and why it totally
makes sense
on june 22nd the same day as wwdc
the reliable analyst minsha kwo
announced that he expects
apple to release a 13-inch macbook pro
and a new 24-inch imac both packing
apple silicon
later this year and he also said that we
should expect one more
intel imac to be launched in q3 of 2020
before the launch of apple silicon now
as far as that intel imac
we've already seen leaked benchmarks
with brand new
10th gen intel chips but we're still
waiting on the launch
and very recently john prosser is saying
that we should expect it to launch
next month in august so we'll just have
to see
back to the apple silicon max ming choco
mentioned that the macbook pro
will not be redesigned this year but
will most likely just have the new arm
chip
and that totally makes sense since the
display size
is going unchanged many other leakers
have also confirmed that the 13.3 inch
macbook pro
is most likely to get apple silicon
first like john prosser and
digitimes which also think the macbook
air is coming this year as well
so i'll talk about that in just a minute
now i'm not totally certain about this
but i expect that only the base model
macbook pro
will be replaced with apple silicon at
first
leaving the 1800 macbook pro with
the 10 gen intel chip which was recently
updated
this way consumers will have a choice
between
intel or apple silicon during this short
transition period
and as far as the 14 inch macbook pro i
personally expect that to come sometime
next year
with a brand new mini led display and an
apple silicon chip
which will replace the current 1800
intel model so by that time next year
users will either have the choice
between the 13.3 inch
arm macbook pro without a redesign or
the more expensive 1800 14 inch macbook
pro
with apple silicon and the new display
and as far as the 16 inch macbook pro
absolutely do not expect an apple
silicon model
to be released until the 14 inch macbook
pro is released next year
and rumors are pointing to a launch date
between june
and august for both of those models now
let's talk about the macbook air
and recent rumors are pointing to that
model being updated with apple silicon
at the same time as the macbook pro now
some people are expecting it to actually
be
a revival of the 12-inch macbook instead
of the macbook air
but let me explain why i don't think
that's the case first off
we haven't seen any rumors pointing to
it being a 12-inch macbook
and second the original 12-inch macbook
required the brand new incredibly thin
butterfly keyboard
which apple has since completely ditched
for the magic keyboard
which is now quite a bit more thick and
personally
i can't stand the 12-inch macbook
because it feels like a toy to me
so based on all of that don't expect the
12-inch macbook to come back
at least not this year now there are
still people commenting on our videos
thinking that these new apple silicon
macs will have touch screen displays
but i seriously doubt that check out
this clip
and yet with all the new capabilities
and advantages that episode can offer
there's one thing that certainly stays
the same max will stay max the way you
know and love them
so that shows that apple wants to keep
max the same
and if you watched my last video you'll
know that apple silk and macs
are gonna run completely unmodified
iphone
and ipad apps right out of the box on
day one
and that's probably the reason why
people are expecting touch screen
displays to come to the mac
but if apple was actually planning that
then they wouldn't go through all the
trouble to make
this work now let's look at an ipad game
monument valley
this app is the exact same one available
in the ios app store
mouse clicks are mapped to tabs i can
zoom in as expected on the trackpad
i can click and drag to rotate and
create a path for our character
the game is fully playable that was a
completely unmodified game
running on an apple silicon mac so apple
is
automatically remapping touch input and
converting it
into mouse pointer input on the mac
check out this next clip we'll be able
to run a higher quality hardware
supported 444 encoder for even better
image quality
when connecting your mac to an ipad with
sidecar apple is improving the quality
of
sidecar which is when you connect your
ipad to your mac
so you can have touch screen support
apple wouldn't be doing any of this
if they were planning on bringing
touchscreen displays to
their macs and now let's just use simple
common sense if the new apple silicon
max
can run iphone and ipad apps unmodified
and apple added touch touchscreen
displays to those macs
there would literally be no point to
keep the ipad pro around
and apple is definitely keeping it
around
so no macs are not getting touchscreen
displays
and as far as the release date of these
new apple silicon macs
some leakers have pointed to an apple
event happening on october
27th which lines up with the dates of
previous
apple october events and as for that new
apple silicon
24-inch imac that we originally thought
was coming this year
we've recently stopped seeing any
mentions of that model
so there's a chance that we won't see it
until next year
now let's move on to the big question
that's on everyone's mind
should i wait for apple silicon or just
buy an
intel-based mac right now well if you're
a student and you
absolutely need a mac before school
starts
then you obviously have no choice since
we're not expecting apple silicon max
to ship until november now if you're in
the market for a 13 inch macbook pro or
a macbook air
then you need to ask yourself what
you're trying to achieve with it
if you want to do some web browsing
netflix watching or using common apps
then you should definitely wait since
apple silicon
will give you much better battery life
and the ability to run
iphone and ipad apps natively
now as far as professional work goes if
you mainly use
apps from either apple microsoft or
adobe
then you should definitely wait because
of this pages numbers and keynote
run great and this is one of the most
demanding pro apps final cut pro
with real-time rendering of several
movie streams and logic our music
creation powerhouse
easily keeping up with large projects we
already worked with a number of our
partners to bring the apps to apple
silicon as well
here's adobe photoshop already taking
advantage of the new architecture
and running fast on this new mac and
microsoft has brought up their office
apps
such as word and excel of course our
developer tools also work great on apple
silicon and can be used to create native
apps
so all of those apps are already running
very well
on apple silicon now if you're a
high-end user
let me remind you that apple most likely
won't release
high-end macs like the 16-inch macbook
pro with apple silicon
until around the summer of 2021
so you have to decide if you want to
wait that long but
if you use very specific editing apps
like resolve
16 studio for your professional work
that makes you money
it may be a good idea to buy an
intel-based mac right now
since there's no knowing how long it'll
take to optimize those apps
for apple silicon and the very last
point is gaming
if your idea of gaming is playing mobile
games like clash of clans
call of duty mobile or fortnite then you
should definitely wait for apple silicon
but if you enjoy aaa titles like
battlefield 5
and call of duty war zone then i would
just buy an intel based mac right now
because it still supports windows 10
using bootcamp
and if you're stuck somewhere in the
middle of all of those scenarios
and your choice depends on how powerful
these apple silicon macs will be
then i would definitely subscribe right
now because in my next video
i'm going to go through a very specific
apple developer video
that actually shows you the performance
of apple silicon
so hopefully you guys enjoyed this video
and if you learned something new
go ahead and tap the like button below
and be sure to check out our premium
apple product mask
down below in our merch shelf which we
also have a white version
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next one
[Music]
you